- [Kim] Hi, this is Kim from Khan Academy.
And today we're learning more
about McDonald v. Chicago,
a 2010 Supreme Court case
challenging a handgun ban
in the City of Chicago.
The question at issue
was whether the 14th
Amendment's Due Process
or Privileges or Immunities Clause
means that the Second Amendment right
to keep and bear arms for
the purposes of self-defense
is applicable to the states.
Or, put more plainly,
the Second Amendment says
the federal government
can't infringe on citizens
rights to keep and bear arms,
but can state governments?
To learn more about McDonald v. Chicago,
I talked to two experts.
Alan Gura is a lawyer who
argued McDonald v. Chicago
before the Supreme Court.
Elizabeth Wydra is a
Supreme Court litigator
and the president
of the Constitutional
Accountability Center.
So, Miss Wydra, could
you set the stage for us?
Who were the challengers in this case
and why did they decide to sue?
- [Elizabeth] The lead
plaintiff was Otis McDonald,
then a 76-year-old African-American
retired maintenance engineer
who lived in a part of Chicago
and wanted to have a gun for self-defense,
a handgun,
to protect himself and
his family at his home.
He lived in a neighborhood
that had grown increasingly troubled
with gang and drug-related violence
and he felt that he
wanted to have a handgun
to protect his wife and his family
after his home had been
broken into several times.
But because the City of Chicago
had strict rules barring handguns,
he and three other Chicago residents
brought their case into court,
asking the Court to find
that the individual right
to keep and bear arms,
including a handgun for
self-defense in the home
that had been recognized
just a few years earlier
by the Supreme Court with respect
to the federal government,
also applies to the states
and cities like Chicago.
- [Alan] In 2008,
the Supreme Court had held
that the Second Amendment
to the Constitution
guarantees Americans
the right to have guns
for the purpose of self-defense.
But that case took
place in Washington, DC,
and Washington, DC,
is sort of a unique creature in our law.
It's a federal city,
it's not located in any particular state,
and so everything that the
City of Washington does
is essentially done by
the federal government
or a unit of the federal government
to which the Bill of
Rights applies directly.
But, historically,
the Bill of Rights was never
thought to apply directly
to limit what cities and states could do.
- [Kim] So, what were some of
the competing interpretations
that were at issue in this case?
- [Alan] Well, there were
a number of interpretations
that were at issue.
The 14th Amendment has
several parts to it.
In the first section of the 14th Amendment
it states that no state
shall make or enforce any law
which shall abridge the
privileges or immunities
of citizens of the United States.
And then it also says, among other things,
that the states can't
deprive people of due process
when it comes time to regulating
their life, liberty, or property.
States may not deprive anyone
of life, liberty, or property
without due process of law.
When it comes to your basic civil rights,
the question had always been
whether or not the states are bound
not to violate your civil rights
because they're told not to abridge
the privileges or immunities
of American citizens,
or are your rights not to be violated
because the states can't deprive
you of due process of law.
- [Elizabeth] So, when the
drafters of the 14th Amendment
were coming together
to think about what
rights would be protected
in the 14th Amendment,
they looked at a a lot of the
abuses by state governments
of key rights that had
been previously protected
against federal government
action in the Bill of Rights.
And when they were debating
what rights would be
included in these protections
against state action,
they talked repeatedly
about the importance
of the right to keep and bear arms.
But the way they talked about it
was very different from the way
that we think about the 18th
century Revolutionary Founders
talking about the right
to keep and bear arms.
In that case it was very
much about the militia
and preventing the tyranny
of government action.
In the 14th Amendment context,
the right to keep and bear arms
was very much an individual right.
They were concerned about freed persons
being subject to white militia violence
and being able to protect themselves
with a gun in their house.
And so that was really one of the ways
in which they wanted to
protect the individual right
to keep and bear arms,
different from the way
that I think the Founders thought about it
when they were drafting
the Second Amendment.
- [Kim] Yeah, this is a
really interesting point
because you can kinda see how
these things evolve over time.
And particularly in the
1860s after the Civil War,
there are many local or state statutes,
know as the Black Codes,
that specifically prevented
newly-freed African-Americans
from owning firearms
or any kind of weapon.
- [Elizabeth] Exactly,
and that was a concern because,
one, it was a right that
they considered to be
a right of citizenship.
But two, and more practically
and more immediately
of concern for the people
who were being targeted
by this racial violence,
it was something that was
a question of life or death
for them.
And the debates on this
by the drafters of the 14th Amendment
were very clear and very colorful.
Senator Samuel Pomeroy
described how indispensable
the right to keep and bear arms was
and how important it was
that the 14th Amendment
protect that right.
He said during the debates,
"Every man should have
the right to bear arms
"for the defense of himself
and family and his homestead.
"And if the cabin door of
the freedman is broken open
"and the intruder enters
"for purposes as vile as
were known to slavery,
"then should a well-loaded musket
"be in the hand of the occupant
"to send the polluted
wretch to another world
"where his wretchedness will
forever remain complete."
- [Kim] So, going back
to the McDonald case,
how did the Court rule in this case?
- [Alan] In McDonald,
we made two arguments
for why we should win.
The first argument we made
was the historically more obvious one,
although it's one that courts
had not often entertained.
In essence, the argument says
that when the 14th Amendment provided
that people cannot be deprived
of the privileges or immunities
of American citizenship,
that means they couldn't be deprived
of their basic fundamental rights.
Right there in text,
the 14th Amendment tells you
that you can't be deprived
of the rights of American citizenship.
Secondly, we made the argument that,
and this is the argument
that the courts have been
more open to over the years,
we made the argument
that where the state is prohibited
from depriving Otis McDonald
and other Chicago residents
of due process of law,
you can't deprive somebody of due process,
that means not just that the state
can't do things arbitrarily,
not just that Otis McDonald
is entitled to some procedural protections
in the way that he's regulated
but also that there are some results,
some things that simply cannot be done.
In taking away someone's firearms
in violation of the
Second Amendment rights,
it's not something that the state can do,
there's no procedure that
the state could create
to achieve that.
They would still be considered
to be giving somebody due process of law.
- [Elizabeth] So, the Court
said what we have done
when we've looked at individual rights
under the 14th Amendment,
and whether or not original
Bill of Rights rights
that were initially understood
to limit the federal government
applied to the states,
it's looked at whether
or not they are part
of what we generally talk about
as fundamental to our
scheme of ordered liberty.
Or, stated another day,
the question is whether
the right is firmly rooted
in this nation's history and tradition.
And when they looked at that question
with respect to the right
to keep and bear arms,
they looked at a lot of
the reconstruction history
and said this was clearly something
that the drafters of the 14th Amendment
considered to be very
fundamental to ordered liberty
and thought that indeed the freed men,
the African-American people of the South
who had been subject to the slave power
and people across the country
who had been subject to
discrimination from the states
should be able to look to the Constitution
to protect the right to keep and bear arms
as their individual right.
Just as the Court had
held in the Heller case,
they could be able to
look to the Constitution
for protection of that right
against the federal government.
- [Kim] So, in the McDonald case,
how did the majority of the Court rule?
- [Alan] The justices broke
down in multiple different ways.
There were four justices,
led by Justice Alito,
who refused to look any further
at the Privileges or Immunities Clause.
They thought it was old, it
was water under the bridge.
They were not interested in looking to see
whether or not the Court's
erasing of that provision
was legitimate,
even if it's widely agreed
to be illegitimate today.
But the Court didn't wanna go there.
And instead those four
justices, led by Justice Alito,
held that the due process clause
incorporates the Second Amendment right
to keep and bear arms
as against the states
because it is a fundamental right,
it's deeply rooted in our
nation's history and traditions,
it's something that's very
basic to our understanding
of our civil and political institutions.
Four justices thought
that the right to keep and
bear arms is fundamental.
- [Elizabeth] So, there
was actually a debate
among the members of the majority
who all believed that there was a right
to have a handgun in the
house for self-defense
that was protected
against state and local
government regulations.
But Justice Thomas would
have found that right
through another means.
He would have looked at the
Privileges or Immunities Clause
of the 14th Amendment
instead of the now accepted method
of looking at the due
process liberty clause
of the 14th Amendment,
which is how these other
provisions of the Bill of Rights
have been incorporated against the states.
There were many arguments,
including I should say
a brief that I filed
on behalf of scholars from
across the ideological spectrum
who said that in fact
the Privileges or Immunities
Clause of the 14th Amendment
is the part of that
constitutional amendment
that was intended to protect
this particular substantive right
as well as the other substantive rights
of the Bill of Rights
against state infringement.
Justice Thomas' concurrence
did not get any other votes,
whether from the people who were against
the right to keep and bear arms
and those who didn't,
but it is an important contribution
to thinking about how we understand rights
and where they are protected
in the Constitution.
- [Alan] Justice Thomas'
opinion in McDonald
is groundbreaking.
It represents the first time since 1868
that the original meaning
of the 14th Amendment's
Privileges or Immunities Clause,
the basic protection that
we have for civil rights
in this country
against state and local governments
was decisive in a case
at the Supreme Court.
It's been that long since a
true original understanding
of the 14th Amendment's language
has finally proven to be decisive.
- [Elizabeth] There
were of course justices
who thought that there is
not an individual right
to have a handgun in the
home for self-defense.
These were the same
justices, not surprisingly,
who thought that there wasn't
a Second Amendment right
to be protected against
federal government action
to keep a handgun in the
home for self-defense.
They would have thought that
this was much more a right
in the Second Amendment context
that had to do with militia
service, military service,
and therefore did not extend
to an individual right
to have a gun in the
home for self-defense.
- [Alan] McDonald's really
a 14th Amendment case.
Guns happened to be the
things that was in it
but I'd always seen it primarily
as a 14th Amendment case.
It's not really a case
that tells you anything
about the scope of the Second Amendment.
In fact, it doesn't say anything
about the scope of the Second Amendment,
very little.
- [Elizabeth] There are many
issues left to be resolved
in the Second Amendment context.
The Heller case itself,
which first articulated
that there was a right for individuals
to keep and bear arms in
their homes for self-defense
made clear that it wasn't saying
that there could be no gun regulation.
That case, even though it was
written by Justice Scalia,
and certainly in the McDonald case
Justice Alito's majority
opinion reiterated this,
said that while there were certain laws
that would be struck
down as unconstitutional
because they prohibited the possession
of handguns in the home,
they recognized at the same time
that the right to keep and bear arms
is not a right to keep and
carry any weapon whatsoever
in any manner whatsoever
and for whatever purpose.
So given that the Court itself,
and even very conservative
justices recognized
that there could be and perhaps should be
common sense limitations
on both the types of
guns that are allowed,
the manner in which they are allowed,
and where they can be
taken and in what manner,
then a lot of the gun
regulations that are being passed
are still very much part of
the constitutional debate.
We've seen frankly most
of the laws thus far
be upheld as constitutional laws
that for example target assault weapons,
high-capacity magazines,
and certain licensing and
registration requirements.
So I think we will see more
cases to define the contours
of the individual right keep and bear arms
as these gun regulations get passed
and as the courts get to pass
upon their constitutionality.
- [Kim] So, we've learned
that the Supreme Court ruled
that the 14th Amendment's
Due Process Clause
that no state can deprive a citizen
of life, liberty, or property
without due process of law
did incorporate the Second
Amendment into the states
under the reasoning
that the right to keep and
bear arms for self-defense
is fundamental to the nation's
scheme of ordered liberty.
According to Alan Gura,
even though this case was about guns,
it was really a 14th Amendment case
concerning whether states can
restrict citizens liberty.
Elizabeth Wydra, however,
cautions that the decision in McDonald
didn't preclude any
restriction on gun ownership,
and she suspects that new
cases will continue to define
the individual right
to keep and bear arms.
To learn more about this case,
visit the National Constitution Center's
Interactive Constitution,
and Khan Academy's resources
on US government and politics.